haven't going through gut issues. I did a colonoscopy and they couldn't get in due to a mass
squishing the colon long story short. The doctor said it was impacted feces all throughout the
intestines stuck. Then in and out of severe pain in the back and diarrhea yet never feeling empty
but going out for nine months how do I get it unstuck without surgery. Why would a person have
diarrhea if they have an impacted colon because the feces that is able to get by the impaction
has to be very watered down and then you have to have a diarrhea beyond that point but you have
an impacted colon with feces that's not necessarily all that uncommon. How do you get it unimpacted?
First of all, your concern is if it truly is simply impacted feces because you've been
constipated for in this case like nine months then you're doing coffee enemas, doing colonics
to try to get that lucid up colonics go much higher deeper than a coffee enemah doing colonics
to try to lucid that up would be something that I would try before you try to go in there and do
something surgically. Sure, they'd probably recommend oral things to help lucid things up.
How does a person get so impacted because many times they've ignored this initial symptoms if
you've been constipated and you've had abnormal stools for a long time and you just think it's
going to go away? Well, this is where it's so important to be on some fiber substances,
some other things such as just straight butyric acid and some other colon
healing things, you know, we've said it in not only the detox, the seven phases of detox course
and my book on seven phases detox, if you're not detoxifying, you're just toxic, you're toxifying.
So if you're not getting out with the inside, if you're not getting rid of poisons,
you are becoming more and more poisoned. That will lead to all sorts of serious disease
that you could just list on a spreadsheet because ultimately it's going to lead to deaths,
you have to get out what's on the inside, you have to get out poisons that are in your body,
you're just if the more constipated you are, you're just going to be reabsorbing all your toxins
that your liver's getting rid of as well.